what do you think happens your operating
assumption for the future of britain we
don't know what's gonna happen but you
have to decide for yourself do I think
Britain's gonna stay in other words not
respect the mandate of the referendum
maybe kind of muddle through with Europe
or perhaps there'll be something more
disorderly my own view is that it's
unlikely that Britain will actually exit
because when it becomes clear that the
terms of the exit are so expensive not
only because the EU is demanding
expensive terms but also the
consequences of leaving are so
significant that I think the next Prime
Minister of England will probably not
invoke article 50 in my view this will
take them maybe a year or two to play
itself out but in my view the
consequences would be too severe for
example if Scotland has a boat to exit
Scotland has the North Sea oil Scotland
has the nuclear submarine bases and
Scotland is a very important part of the
UK if they were to exit it would not be
a good thing for Britain and then surely
know that Ireland would want all soon
absolutely so not so Great Britain any
longer remember it be Little Britain
yeah 52 48 vote democracy doesn't say
that whenever you have a majority that
absolutely requires you to do something
so in our Constitution for example if
you want to get a treaty approved by the
Senate it takes two-thirds if you want
to amend the Constitution it takes
two-thirds of each house and
three-quarters of the states so it's not
exactly the case that that a 52-48 vote
means you have to do something this was
not a binding vote whether the Prime
Minister regretted or not that's another
issue but I think in the end the next
Prime Minister of England I think will
take a hard look at it they'll assess
the terms my own view obviously not
based on inside information my own view
and based on general knowledge is it's
unlikely that Britain will actually exit
in one or two years it may negotiate for
a while but in the end I think the terms
are gonna be too expensive
many people are hopeful David that
you're right but let let's for
argument's sake say that you're wrong
and Britain does I have been wrong
before in my life yes would that make
Carlisle inclined to do less business or
reduce its presence in the UK or Europe
for that matter the devil is always in
the details so what are the terms of the
exit we don't know they're probably
going to be expensive I think some of
the large banks might have to make
changes in what they do in terms of
their operations I don't
they know yet what the terms of the exit
are so I couldn't say what we would do
but I I'm reasonably optimistic that
Britain will the end come to its senses
or the government leaders will come to
those senses and recognize that a brexit
is not in anybody's interests how do you
think financial markets prediction
markets and for that matter just about
every established leader in Europe and
elsewhere for that matter got it wrong
and breaks it well it is interesting
that the polling firms the the the
betting operations that the leaders
nobody really got it right maybe that's
because the you know there's a shift at
the base at the very last minute maybe
in the last hour or two or a couple days
before the vote there was a big shift
maybe because people are just too
distant from the people actually did the
voting many of people who voted against
it were in parts of the of England that
a lot of the leaders don't actually
spend a lot of their time in so there
may be many factors it does make one
wonder about the polling system in
England because they got it wrong on
Cameron's election they didn't really
predict he was gonna have an
overwhelming victory but we are where we
are and I think the most important thing
to do is to not panic not say that the
world is falling apart the world will
survive this it's just not something
that's gonna happen overnight and all of
a sudden to have a calamity it's gonna
take a long time before we know what the
consequences are and I think already
we've seen a rebound in the market the
markets are coming back a bit they're
not back to where they were but they're
coming back a bit as people realize it's
a long term operation before we know
what's going on does it make you David
do anything differently as the co-ceo of
Carlisle or the firm do anything
differently because the uncertainty that
we've been living with already now seems
to be deeper and maybe more prolonged
and that can create challenges as an
asset management opportunities as well
there's no doubt that there's probably
going to be a slowdown the UK economy
and we have to take that into account as
we look at companies we want to buy
there we have to assume that the economy
is going to grow at a lower rate and
perhaps it makes some difference in
financing things we don't know yet but
we should also take a look at around the
world are there any other brexit that
could happen are we assuming that
something won't happen then it might
actually happen so I think a
geopolitical assessment of other
possible brexit around the world is a
good thing to do